うわー…
あのー
偏頭痛の人どれぐらいいますか？
なんかこの季節台風とか低気圧がすごくて
今日朝起きてからずーっと頭が痛くて
なんか今も正直トンカチがあれば…
あ。
あったわ＾＾
もう例えていうとほんとにトンカチで
頭ぶち割りたいぐらい頭が今痛いでございます
はじめしゃちょーです
あぁダメだ もうしゃべっても痛い…
あの ちょっとほんとにしゃべると頭に響くんで
ちょっと今日は軽めに済ませようと思います…
軽めに済ましたいんですけども
結構デカいことです 今日は…！
あの…
珍しく事務所の方から
「はじめさん・・・」みたいな
「はじめさん…ちょっと…やばいっス」
みたいな感じで来まして
で、なんだろうと思って それが今ここにあります
ちょっと開けてみますね 一回
名前は書いてなかったです
送り先の人が分からなかったんで
ほんとに誰が届けたんだろうって感じですね
クマさんのシールと遊戯王カードが入っています
で、裏には手紙が入っています
パッと見 すごいカードが入ってますね…
手紙はちょっと最後にします
ちょっと見ていきますね この中身
結構 遊戯王カードだらけなんですね
おぉすごい…「ハーピィズペットドラゴン」
おお！「オシリスの天空竜」
あ！ウリアだ…！
兄弟みたいなカードが入ってる…
あぁすげぇ めっちゃキラキラしてるなぁ
はいはいはい…
「レッドアイズ・ブラックメタルドラゴン」…
鋼炎竜(フレアメタルドラゴン)…
すごいドラゴンパレードや！
あー最近のパックですね
おぉ「ブラック・マジシャン」じゃん
うわすげぇ「ブラック・マジシャン・ガール」じゃん！
これどこかで買ってくれたのかな…？
わぁすげぇ ラー…
うぇぇ 青眼(ブルーアイズ)だ
あ、オベリスクだ…
すごいめちゃくちゃくれてるじゃん
…
… …
… … …
う”わ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”
(荒い鼻息)
アァァ頭痛い頭痛い…
あぁ偏頭痛が痛いけど
すごいんですよ！！これ！！！
これ！！すごいんですよ！！！
（2回目）
ちょっと待って…？
はい というわけでいろんなカード送ってくれたんですけども
これはちょっと ほんとに…！
あのちょっとまって これマジで
なんで俺に送ったの！？
いや…
ありがとうございますm(_ _)m
これはさすがに取り上げるべき代物かなと
思いまして取り上げてしまいました
これ…遊戯王知ってる人なら知ってると思うんですけど
っていうカードで
やっばいよこれ！
多分 値段聞くとみんな
このカード自体そんな強いカードではないんですけど
純粋にレア…！！
えっと、現在…
しかないカードです
これは流石に僕は ちょっと…
もらって黙っている訳にはいかなかったんで
動画にしてしまいました
これやばいよ… 本当に…
もう見た感じ分かると思うんですけど
すごい神々しいんですよね カード自体が
遊戯王カードってイラストにサインとか書いてないんですけども
ホルアクティに関してはサインが書いてあるという…
久しぶりにちょっと…
動揺しました
これちょっとAmazonで値段調べてみましょうか…
あんまりもらった物の値段とか調べたくないですけど
こればかりは価値がすごいんで…
ええと、Amazonでホロアクティ見たんですけども
一番安くて…
(;ﾟДﾟ)エェェ！！？？
いやこれ送った人マジ何考えてんの！？
いやいや ありがとうございますm(_ _)m
ありがとうございますなんですけど
受け取っていいのかなっていう…
もらっちゃっていいのかなって思ったんですけど
誰から送られてきたかわかんないんすよ
だからどうしようもないんで…
ありがたくいただきます
でもほんとに大切にします
ありがとうございます
で、問題の手紙ですよ！
この人はいったいどういう意図でこの
頭痛いな…
いったいこの人はどういう意図で僕にホロアクティを
送ったのか っていうのが
この手紙に書いてあります
ごめんね…送ってくださった方申し訳ないんですけども
名前も書いてないので 読んじゃいますね
「はじめしゃちょー様 こんにちは
遊戯王カードで『赤い竜のカード』が欲しいと
YouTubeで言っていたので
ネットで探しました
遊戯王のことはよくわかりませんが
とにかく竜のカードを買ってみました
頑張ってください」
「よくわかんないけど竜のカード買ってみた」て言って
ホロアクティ買ってるのかな…？
うわ…すっ…いや……うわぁ……
ありがとうございますm(_ _)m
「赤い竜のカードを見つけたのですが
黒と青も買ったのでプレゼントします」
アバウトだな この人…
「嫌がらせに負けずに頑張ってください
ファンで応援しています
体に気を付けて元気で笑顔でいてください
遠くから はじめんが幸せになるように
毎日神様に祈っています
それでは」
いやほんとにありがとうございます
あの 全部嬉しいんですけども…
ヤバいよ
いやでも嬉しいです ほんとにありがとうございます
けど…あんまり こう……ね
多分価値が分からなくて買ったのかも
しれないですけど
ちょっと……ね…
やばいっすよ…
やばいっす
もう 受け取って僕も嬉しいんですけども
ちょっとタジタジしてしまうんですけど
本当に でも ありがとうございます
世界に10000枚しかないカードの1枚が
僕の手元に来てしまいました
ビビったし 送ってくださった方の意図も
また面白いですね…
その中にどさくさに紛れて…
という…